مساء الخير ربما يكون اسهل مدخل انه احنا
نفهم معنى واهميه مشروع يوم العملاق اللي
اعلن عنه الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد
السعودي ثم اربعه وعشرين اكتوبر الفين
وسبعه عشر اللي احنا نفهم معناه بدايه يوم
مكونه من مقطعين نيو يعني مقطع يعني كل ما
لاتيني بمعنى الجديد والام يعني مستقبل
بالعربي من يوم عامي بالمستقبل الجديد
والحقيقه انه كل شيء في يوم كما يتصور هو
وضع على الورق جديد على السعوديه المنطقه
والعالم المشروع ضخمه جدا مكون من سته
وعشرين الف كيلومتر مربع يبدا من شمال غرب
السعوديه في منطقه تبوك و بيمر بالحدود
الاردنيه ثم يعبر الى مصر عن طريق كبرى
كبير اه حدود العشره كيلو في البحر الاحمر
الا عند ان بتعطوا او اساساته ترتكز على
جزيره تيران وصنافير اللي انتقلت سياده اه
من عليهم من المصريه الى السعوديه في 2016
ثم تصل ام الجسر او المشروع يمتد الى جنوب
جنوب سيناء ويتكامل مع محور قناه السويس
العملاق المشروع المصري وبعدين تصل كل
الوقائع الى البحر المتوسط كل البضائع
السعوديه والخليج والمنطقه المنطقه عباره
تبقى عباره عن منطقه اقتصاديه خاصه اي
انها لا تخضع لكل القوانين اللي بتحكم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لها اه اه
الاجراءات الخاصه
خاصه بها فيما يتعلق باجراء الضرائب قريه
الضرائب اللي
المعامله القوانين اختصر القصه اليوم هي
مثال السعوديه الجديده كما يراها الامير
محمد الامير محمد عنده هدف من ال من يوم
الهدف مرتبط ب المشكله الاساسيه باللي
فيها واللي تكلم عنها في خمسطاشر وهو انه
السعوديه اللي اكبر اقتصاد في ال
اكبر اقتصاد العربي وسبعمائه مليار دولار
تقريبا سنويا حجم الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
عندها ازمه كبيره جدا انها تعتمد بالنسبه
حوالي تسعين في المائه على البترول صحيح
السعوديه عندها بتقول يكفيها لعشرات
السنوات
لكن البترول سوف ينفذ والاهم من انه هو
سوف ينفذ على المدى القصير والمتوسط صاروا
متقلبه جدا وتنخفض احيانا الى مستويات
تؤدي او تضع المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
مازق الحل في التنويع
والتنويع هو الهدف من منطقه نيون منطقه ن
يوم اه تبقى مخصصه الى الكل الصناعات اللي
فيها اعتقال هو حوالي تسعه
صناعات اساسيه لكن نقدر نقول بدون الدخول
في تفاصيل كثيره كلها صناعات مرتبطه بال
تكنولوجيات والعلوم الرقميه الحديثه اللي
هي قوام ما يسمى بالثوره الصناعيه الرابعه
بالاضافه ل للطاقه والمياه
والسياحه والصناعه وابحاث المائه طبعا
مهمه جدا فيها وانه الهدف من ال المدينه
مش انه هي تبقى مصدر لخلق وظائف للسعوديين
وهو معدوم نسبه بطاله عليها ولكن انها
تبقى حق مركز لكل الافراد الراغبين في
انهم يجدوا حاضره ومكان مشجع جدا للتكريم
في المجالات المختلفه اللي تقام فيها
المدينه حضرتكم كل شيء في المدينه الجديده
على الورق يعني مثلا عدد الروب او الانسان
الالي كما يقول الوضع والمشروع يكون اكثر
من عدد البشر في بعض فترات المدينه
انهم يقوموا بيقول الاعمال الروتينيه
اذا كان من النظافه
النظافه وحراسه كل الوظائف
البروتينيه البسيطه بحيث يتفرغ البشر
الموجودين لاعمال ابداعيه او اذا كانوا من
المرشحين يستمتعوا ضفاف وسواحل البحر
الاحمر وكل الترفيه اللي ممكن يقام هناك
من حيث شكل المدينه المدينه الحقيقه لما
تيجي تتامل بقطع النظر عن الكلام اللي
موجوده تجد انه في القلب من هذا النقطه
حضرتكم عمليه التنويع لكن يكون الفكره هي
عمليه محاوله استنساخ فكره دبي لكن على
نطاق اوسع
ايه فكره دبي دبي منطقه موجوده في الخليج
ما عندهاش مزايا كثيره يعني معظم شهور
السنه حر جدا وبتوصل درجه الحراره في
الصيف الى حوالي خمسين درجه حراره انما
كانت الميزه الاساسيه في دبي طبعا موقعها
كيف لكن ما تمش الموقع بس لانه في بلاد
اخرى عندها موقع مشاركه دبي كانت فكره ان
يقدم ما كان عنده استعداد انه يعمل
التشريعات تفصلها او تميزها عن باقي دول
الخليج كله دول الخليج كل منطقه محافظه
جدا وبالتالي يصعب على الناس من خارج
المنطقه انه هم يتصرفوا وحريه سواء حريه
في التعامل او في التصرف او في الاقامه
التعالي انت تقدر تصرف في دبي تصرفوا
تقريبا في دول اخرى كثيره في اوروبا فاهلا
بكم بلد
قواعده ومناخ ويسمح للجميع العربي القراني
القران واللى عاوزه المسكينه المس بيكيلي
هو حر في مناخ جدا من اه اعمال ومناخ سلوك
متاح فنادق دبي ضمن عوامل اخرى نات بل
البزنس والتجاره في كل مكان وتبقى هي
الفناء الخلفي او المركز الان كل دول
الخليج ومن دبي كل الشركات يمكن ان تمارس
نشاطها في هذه المنطقه الحيويه من العالم
وعاوز
يعني عنده سعوديه قديمه اليوم هي السعوديه
الجديده السعوديه هذا المكان المتحفظ اللي
اه طبعا كلنا نعرفه هو سياسيا مغلق
ملكيه مطلقه اه البزنس ايضا مغلقا من نظام
الكفيل على المستوى الثقافي مجتمع مغلق
فيه صعوبه للحركه للاجانب يمنع دخول
الاجانب في بعض المدن والاماكن المقدسه
من غير المسلمين حركه المراه عليها قيود
اختلاط الجنسين كل كثير يعني كلام كله
يعني تحصيل حاصل هو نريد ان يقفز على كل
الكلام دا وينشا سعوديه جديده في اليوم
حيث المكان يكون مرحب بكل ال اه البشر
نساء ورجالا يشعروا انهم بيتصرف فيه اليوم
في منطقه يوم زي ما بيتصرفوا مثلا في شرم
الشيخ بمصر في زي اي مدينه اوروبيه يضاف
الى كده انه المنطقه مش بس دبي تم دبي
بس ب اه يعني افكار حتى سابقا دول اخرى
كثيره في العالم
الاستثمارات نوعيه اذا في الاستثمارات اه
وعلوم جديده لحضراتكم عليها المدينه
تواجهها
مشكلتين اساسيتين في الوقت الحالي
المشكله الاولانيه انه تتعلق ب بعض
المتاعب
السياسيه يعني او بعض التحديات السياسيه
وبعض التحديات الماليه تحتى السياسي
الاولاني او
الجيوبوليتيكال يعني ال
انه انت المنطقه كلها طبعا انا اريد كثير
كل الكلام بيتكلم على انه المنطقه تبقى
اول منطقه اقتصاديه تبقى عابره للحدود
يعني دائما المنطقه الاقتصاديه سواء من
اول شي اول منطقه اقتصاديه انشائها الصين
وبعدين حول الدين يقول لا تستنسخ ها وليك
عملت في شان مجتمع بردو مغلق وعنده مشاكل
وعاوز يعزل منطقه يقول دي لها قواعد خاصه
تبقى فيها مرونه استبقتها دبي استنزفت ها
اماكن اخرى في مصر في الاردن في كثير من
دول العالم يعني الى الدول الكثير اول
منطقه
تتجاوز الحدود يعفيها ال الاردن يبقى فيها
مصر بين قوسين انا مش قادر افهم او دور
الاردن حتى الان كل بس اللي انا بشوف انه
حيبقى وجود الاردني يتيح يعني اه مساحه
اكبر من سواحل البحر الاحمر هم ليس بين
شوايه الاردن ممكن ان تشهد كثير في
المنطقه انما الاردن منذ الاعلان وحتى
الان جزء اساسي من المنطقه لكن بالنسبه
الى دور مصر واضح شويه
الاساسي لانه المنطقه من تم محطه انها
تربك اسيا باوروبا وطبعا افريقيا يكون
موجود بحكم انه مصر دوله اسيويه
افريقيه
وبالتالي الهدف مهم جدا ان وصل البحر
الاحمر والسعوديه لها اطلاله على البحر
الاحمر لكن عاوزه توصل الى الساحل
الافريقي
البحر الاحمر وتصل من سيناء تصل الى البحر
المتوسط قرب تقول البضائع اللي موجوده
بتكلفه ارخص من السعوديه ومنطقه اليوم
الجديده او السعوديه الجديده اسيا كلها
اوروبا وكذلك ال القادم ال ال البضائع
القادمه من اوروبا الى اه الخليج والى
اسيا جيد جدا عن طريق المعبر والمعبر ده ب
يمتد من سبعه عشره كيلو على البحر الاحمر
ومن من السعوديه الى سنه او بن سينا
الحروب
المشاكل
وتتعلق بان والتحدي الاساسي انه في دول
كثيره مهتمه بالمشروع وده امريكيه بس فيه
دول مهتمه اهتمام عادي انه انا مهتم لانه
مشروع كبير تكلفته حوالي خمسمائه مليار
دولار في فرص عمل هائله جدا و للشركات
والافراد
لكن في دول معينه مهتمه باهتمام اكثر شويه
اكثر دولتين عندهم اهتمام بالقصه هو ال
اسرائيل والصين بالنسبه للصين بالنسبه
للاسف لاسرائيل المشروع كله على بعضه على
بعد عده كيلومترات من بين ايلات يعني على
بعد كيلومترات دائما اسرائيل اثنين
الكبرى الها يعبر الهياه السعوديه مصر هو
الحقيقه يقام جزء منه او ما كان يمكن ان
يكمل لولا ان سوف تقام بعض الدعائم على
جزيره تيران وصنافير اللي انتقلت زي ما
قلت لحضرتك م السياده عليهم من مصر الى
السعوديه في 2016 طيب معنى كده ان وفقا
لاتفاقيه السلام المصريه الاسرائيليه في
تسعه وسبعين بتكفل هذه الاتفاقيه سلامه
وامن
العبور لكل السفن التجاريه والعسكريه
الاسرائيليه في هذا المضيق الى اغلاقه ادى
الى حرب سبعه وستين او كان من ضمن العوامل
ادت الى حرب سبعه وستين
معنى كده انه لا بد ان يكون هناك تنسيق
قانوني على الاقل ما بين السعوديه وما بين
اسرائيل
12 وهو ما فيش حتى الان علاقه رسميا اثنين
ان القرب الشديد
اليوم الى اسرائيل يجعل من اسرائيل اه
بيقولوا عليها ستكون في التعبير
وستكون
المستثمر في شركه او في مشروع تساهم
في حالات من الاردن ومصر انما ممكن يبقى
واحد يعني مش مشارك لكن صاحب مصلحه كبيره
جدا في المشروع ابسط مثال زي مثلا اهل
البصره في مصر المدينه المشهوره جدا
المشاركين في الاثار الكبيره اللي موجوده
لكن هم المستفيدين جدا من اي رواق
يحدث يحدث لهذه الاماكن زيارتها المتضررين
من اي انخفاض من اعداد السائحين هناك
وبالتالي اسرائيل بتراقب المساله مش بس
بتراقب المساله لانها قريبا وانها قادره
ان تشارك في هذا المشروع هي كذلك والدول
العربيه كذلك بقدر كبير جدا هي صاحبه
التقدم الاكبر في التكنولوجيا اللي
المدينه بتحاول ان هي اه تبقى حبلى الامر
الثاني ان عندها ايضا اطلاله على البحر
المتوسط وبالتالي ممكن جدا انها عندها ما
تقدم
السن
للمشروع من عده زوايا هي بتشوف انه
المنطقه كلها جزء من مشروع الحزام والطريق
اللي بيوفر معابر وشركاء على مستوى العالم
كله اللي تجارتها وصناعتها
اكثر اهتماما بمشاركه بالمشاركه في
المشروع في كل الاحوال لكن حماس يزيد لو
ان اسرائيل من القصه لعده اسباب سياسيه
ابدا معناه استقرار المنطقه وبالتالي
استقرار لمصالحها
اثنين اسرائيل اه اه او شريك اساسي لها في
مشروع الحزام والطريق وكان في الصين
بتحاول تمول مشروع اه خط سكك الحديد من
ميناء ايلات في الجنوب اللي اجدود على
البحر المتوسط
بحيث يكون مشروع مكمل وليس منافس لقناه
السويس وبالتالي ما عندها بدائل مختلفه ها
تبقى مبسوطه ان اسرائيل تدخل في القصه
وبالتالي لا يكفل لها من فشله في صناعات
هي تشارك فيها في المنطقه يعني باعتبار ان
المنطقه كلها معبر
من المعابر كثيره
الحريصه ان هي تعمل ها في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط ضمن مشروع الحزام كل هذا التحدي
بيمثل تحدي لان الصحيه حتى الان ما فيش
على قدره سميه بينها وبين اسرائيل
والبعض باعتقد ان اليوم قد تحتم عمليه
التطبيع واعلان السلام خصوصا ان فيه
علاقات انا تكلمت عنها اكثر من مره قائمه
سرا وبشكل الرسم المتزايده باعتبار ان
الرياض تل ابيب
الى اثنين بيت معهم تحالف سريه وغير معلن
لمواجهه ايران طيب لكن بردو ما زال يمثل
تحدي خصوصا ان دورها يقتضي من الامير محمد
بن سلمان انه حيوانيه الجبهه الداخليه
اللي كثير منها يرفض التطبيع والسلام مع
اسرائيل طيب على المستوى المالي مشروع
اليوم معاقبه كبيره ان المشروع بيتكلف
حوالى خمسمائه مليار دولار وال خمسمائه
مليار دولار دول اه تمول هم ليس سهلا يعني
كان ال م ال ال ال ال مصادر التمويل
المعلنه انه يكون من ال الدوله من الخزنه
الدوله من الصندوق السيادي ومن
المستثمرين الاجانب المستثمر الاجنبي
مشاهدي اللي لما انت تبدا
ويشوف حاجه على الارض فهو كان المتخيل انه
في جزء قد يعني بيدرسوا انه ياتي من
الصندوق السيادي ولكن الصندوق السالم
عندوش كثيره او كده لغايه 2018
الصندوق السياده للسعوديه بيقدر استثمارات
بحوالي مائتين
وثلاثين مليار دولار فقط يعني رقم تقريبا
10 او 11 على مستوى العالم
ممكن عندهم وصدر اخرى اللي هي الاحتياطي
لكن الاحتياطيه تراجع الى حد ما وحجم
الاحتياطات اللي موجوده احتياطي النقد
خمسه مليار بارقام 2018
فكان متخيل ان يكون من مصادر مختلفه زي
مثلا ان
يطرح مشروع اليوم كل كمشروع في البورصات
العالميه
بس لازم المشروع يقوم الاول وبعدين يبقى
كذاب ففكره كانت الفكره الاساسيه اي معنى
انه يطرح جزء من
للاكتتاب العام اللي كان مطروح من
حوالي سنتين ثلاثه واللي تعثر من منذ
الطرح من ثلاثين ثلاثه لكن تعثر من حوالي
السنه
لاسباب تكلمنا عنها قبل كده وبالتالي جزء
كبير من الاموال اللي كانت هي من خاصه
خمسه فيه منهم كان تذهب الى هذا المشروع
العملاق تؤجل العمليه الطرح ل 2020 2021
الان اذا لم يتم عمليه طرح الخمسه في
الميادين المشروع برمته والصعوبه
فاحنا عندنا صعوبات
يعني سياسيه وعندنا صعوبات
ماليه تقف امام مشروع
المشروع العملاق خصوصا يعني ان المستثمرين
عاوزين يتاكدوا من الجديه لانهم تجارب
اخرى
يعني تفتكر مثلا الفين وخمسه السعوديه
طرحت مجموعه كبيره من المشروعات بردو
اظنكم سته ايام الملك عبد الله وكان في
بردو يعني ابتعاد كثير بيهم اه زي مدينه
الملك عبد الله الاقتصاديه
واللي كان المفروض انه الكوكب بيقول يبقى
فيها حوالي اثنين مليون نسمه وكذا لكن
حقيقه انه حتى الان لم تلقى اي نجاح عدد
الناس اللي موجودين فيها عده الاف او ال
الحي المالي مثلا ال بردو الملك عبد الله
التي شمال الرياض ما بين كثيره اكثر من
سبعين بدنا لكن ما فيش والى شركه استثمار
وحده كان مفروض المنافذ ما فيش حد كلها
ربما انا طبعا اليوم ما يكون مختلف لان
وراء حماس شديد جدا من الامير محمد بن
سلمان وده يقدر يديها دفعه لكن لغايه
النجاح المشروع كل مرتبط بقدره الامير
محمد بن سلمان ان يجيب على اسئله كثيره
جدا حتى ينجح هذا حتى ينجح هذا المشروع
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]